how are you coordinating and managing
your workflows
if you're using cron jobs with custom
scripts you know that it can get super
tricky to stitch together all of your
services and applications together to
build a workflow especially as your
workflow scales in size and complexity
in this video we'll explore some of the
orchestration services that google cloud
has to support your workflows so what is
orchestration
orchestration refers to the automated
configuration coordination and
management of computer systems and
services
you can think of orchestration as the
process of stitching all of your
services and applications together to
build an end-to-end workflow
perhaps you want to automate the
execution of a single service at a
specific time of the day
or maybe you have a more sophisticated
approach of not just automating one
service but automating coordinating and
monitoring multiple services over longer
periods of time there are several
orchestration tools that google cloud
has to help support your workflows these
include cloud scheduler for scheduling
single repetitive tasks
workflows for complex multi-service
orchestration and cloud composer for
data-driven workloads
first we have cloud scheduler
cloud scheduler is a simple scheduling
tool that allows you to schedule the
execution of a single http based service
on a recurring schedule you define
many customers use scheduler alongside
other google cloud tools like pub sub
and cloud functions to execute their
code in a serverless manner
cloud scheduler is great if you need to
call a single service at regular
intervals
for example you could use cloud
scheduler to schedule the execution of a
cloud function that sends out daily
emails with top news stories about
technology
but what if you have multiple services
that you need to chain together feeding
the output of one service to the next
or what if you need to apply complex
logic to determine how and when services
are invoked
this brings us to workflows
workflows is a service for orchestrating
multiple http based services into a
durable and stateful workflow
like cloud scheduler workflows allows
you to automate the execution of http
services running on cloud functions and
cloud run as well as external services
and apis
but unlike scheduler workflows gives you
the power to connect multiple
microservices as part of a larger
workflow
when you create your workflow you can
use either yaml or json
you specify the order of the services as
well as how the result of one step can
be used as either an input to the next
step or as a condition to determine
which step to execute next
workflows is perfect for chaining
together microservices automating
infrastructure tasks like starting or
stopping a bm
and integrating reliably with external
systems
to execute a workflow you can manually
trigger it via an api call or in the
cloud console or you can set up a
recurring schedule with cloud scheduler
if your focus is on engineering data
pipelines or big data processing
you should consider cloud composer
composer is a service designed to
orchestrate data driven workflows and is
built on the popular open source apache
airflow project
since it's a fully managed service you
don't have to worry about managing
airflow deployments
composer takes care of infrastructure
management for you so you can focus on
actually building your data pipelines
it also supports your pipelines wherever
they are whether that be on-premise or
across multiple cloud platforms
like workflows you create a task for
each step in your workflow configure the
order of the tasks and specify which
tasks to execute next based on some
conditions
tasks are expressed as a python directed
acyclic graph also known as a dag that
can be scheduled to run at a time of
your choice or in response to a
particular event
operators allow you to communicate with
services across multiple cloud
environments and on-prem
in addition to many operators in the
apache airflow ecosystem there are over
150 operators for google cloud alone
for example your composer workflow might
start by triggering a data ingestion job
in bigquery then started batch
processing dataflow pipeline and finally
send a slack notification to teammates
that the data processing workload has
finished
both composer and workflows are great
for orchestrating multiple services and
handling long-running workflows
however there are several key
differences to highlight
composer is designed for orchestration
of the transformation of data as part of
etl or data engineering workflows
workflows on the other hand is focused
on the orchestration of http based
services built with cloud functions
cloud run and external apis
while composer is designed for
orchestrating batch workloads that can
handle a few seconds of delay between
tasks
workflows is designed for more latency
sensitive use cases
while composer tasks can be modeled as a
directed acyclic graph
workflows can work for use cases where
you need loops and jumps to already
executed steps
so there you have it an introduction to
orchestration in google cloud and how
you can use scheduler composer and
workflows to manage and configure your
services
check out the next video on data
orchestration with cloud composer
you